تنضم إلي الآن من رالا في
الضفة الغربية المحتلة
السياسية الفلسطينية ومفاوض السلام حنان
عشراوي حنان عشراوي مرحبا بكم في
برنامجنا، لذا هل يمكنني أن أطلب منكم أولا
التعليق على الأخبار التي تغمر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بالصور الرهيبة أم
وما نحن عليه  'سمعت من طبيب في
غزة أه بالقرب من
مخيم جباليا نعم إنه أمر مفجع للغاية إنه أمر
غير معقول ست
قنابل ضخمة أه انفجرت على مخيم للاجئين،
مخيم اللاجئين الأكثر كثافة سكانية
في المنطقة الأكثر كثافة سكانية في
العالم وعدد القتلى هو  غير
معروف حتى الآن، يقول بعض الأشخاص إنك تعرف 400 أو
500 وما إلى ذلك، لكن لا يمكنك معرفة ذلك
لأن المباني العديدة بأكملها
تحولت إلى أنقاض، وقد تم تدمير كتلة كاملة من
المباني المتجاورة بالكامل،
والناس يبحثون عنها،
والناس يبحثون عن الجثث
يخرجون مجرد أشلاء وأذرع
وابن أطفال النساء هؤلاء
كانوا أشخاصًا كانوا في منازلهم وتم
قصفهم وقصفهم بوحشية شديدة وبشكل
متعمد للغاية حتى
الآن قامت إسرائيل أه بتفجير 18 ألف
طن من المتفجرات على أه غزة  وهذا
أكثر من قنبلة هيروشيما، فما
يحدث الآن هو مجرد
تصعيد آخر في مذبحة وحشية في
إبادة جماعية مستمرة والتي
يراها العالم كله ولا يستطيع أن
يفعل أي شيء حيال ذلك لأن إسرائيل هي التي
تفعل ذلك وهي تفعل ذلك.
تجربة مؤلمة للغاية لجميع
الفلسطينيين لأنها تذكرنا بدرجة
أكبر بالنكبة،
الكارثة التي حلت بالفلسطينيين
عندما تم إنشاء إسرائيل نتيجة
لسلسلة من المجازر والتشريد
والطرد، هل يمكنني أن أسألك
شيئًا
كان 1400 إسرائيلي قد تعرضوا له؟  مجزرة
7 أكتوبر، وتبين أن كل هذه
الاستطلاعات تظهر أن الفلسطينيين في
غزة في الواقع لا يتبعون حماس
أغلبيتهم على أي حال، ولا
أعلم عنهم في الضفة الغربية ولكن ما هو
الخيار غير الهزيمة كما  وهو
ضد أجندتك السياسية السياسية، كما تعلم،
أجندة سياسية ضد
السلطات الفلسطينية المعترف بها،
الأجندة السياسية لم تفعل شيئًا أبدًا
لشعب فلسطين ماذا
ستقول هو
البديل حسنًا، أعتقد أنه لو كان لدينا
سلام أه نشط لو كان لدينا
المشاركة الدولية للحد من
الانتهاكات الإسرائيلية والعنف الإسرائيلي وما
إلى ذلك، فهذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة ليس فقط لكبح جماح
حماس ولكن لتحقيق منطق
السلام والتعايش بدلاً من ذلك، كما قلت،
يُسمح لإسرائيل بالاستمرار في الإفلات من
العقاب والعنف الذي تمارسه، كما تعلمون
ذلك  لقد تم قصف غزة خمس مرات قبل
هذا الشيء الأخير ليس انتقامًا أنهم
يواصلون قصف غزة لقد قتلوا
الآلاف قبل أن تصبح غزة
سجنًا ضخمًا الآن وهم
محتجزون بدون طعام بدون ماء
بدون دواء بدون وقود أه بدون
أي شيء هذه ضخمة  الجرائم المسموح
بحدوثها، لذا إذا
واصلت ارتكاب المزيد من نفس الشيء، فسوف
تحصل على المزيد من نفس الشيء، وسوف
تولد المزيد من الاستياء، والمزيد من الغضب،
والمزيد من العداء، والمزيد من الانتقام،
الطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكن لإسرائيل أن تتمتع بها بأي نوع من
الأمن  هو أنه إذا حصل الفلسطينيون على
حقوقهم، فهذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة للتمكن من تحقيق
الأمن في المنطقة والسلام
وما وراءها، ولكن طالما أن
إسرائيل تتصرف
دون أي قيود أو قيود أو
مساءلة وبوحشية كاملة
مع تجريد
الفلسطينيين من إنسانيتهم ​​وشيطنتهم.  الشعور بأنها تستطيع أن
تفعل أي شيء تريده بهم،
ولن يكون هناك سلام، لذا
عليهم أن يفهموا التعامل مع
القضايا الأساسية، التعامل مع الاحتلال
نفسه، التعامل مع نظام الفصل العنصري،
فهم أن الفلسطينيين
لديهم حقوق متساوية مثل الفلسطينيين  الحق
في حريتهم، وكرامتهم،
وسيادتهم على أرضهم، ومن
ثم ستحصلون على السلام، ولكن طالما
كنتم تعتقدون أن بإمكانكم الاستمرار في القتل والمذبحة
وإطلاق النار والتدمير،
فسوف تحصلون على السلام أبدًا، وهذا هو
النهج الخاطئ للقيام بذلك  هذه
وصفة مؤكدة لمزيد من المذبحة
والمزيد من إراقة الدماء